Viserys Targaryen: When he looked east, he
saw the past: old, tired, dead.
But when he looked west, he saw the future:
gold in the ground, gold in the fields, and
no dragons in the sky but his.
He and his sisters, Rhaenys and Visenya, flew
over the great continent, ostensibly visitors
to a strange land.
But when Aegon returned, he ordered construction
of a massive table carved in the shape of
Westeros, with all the notable rivers and
mountains that they had seen.
A personal map of the Seven Kingdoms, then
ruled by seven squabbling families.
House Durrandon held the Stormlands from their
seat at Storm's End, due south of Dragonstone.
House Hoare of the Iron Islands had also conquered
and enslaved the Riverlands, and ruled them
from Harrenhal, a monstrous castle rising
on the shore of the Gods Eye.
House Stark held the frozen wasteland of the
North, the oldest, largest, and emptiest of
the kingdoms.
House Lannister held the Westerlands, the
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their gold mines.
House Gardener held the Reach, the second
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their crops.
House Arryn held the Vale, or rather the Vale
held them.
The mountains were impassable except through
the Bloody Gate, which had never been taken.
House Martell held the deserts of Dorne, probably
because no one else wanted them.
Together, the Seven Kingdoms made Westeros,
a realm that wasn't yet a realm, ruled by
great families who didn't know what greatness
was.
Aegon would teach them.
Varys: Though House Durrandon titled themselves
"Storm Kings," they were little more than
gusts.
Their kingdom in the Stormlands had been doddering
to its end for the past few centuries, helped
along by other houses.
Most of all by House Hoare, who were nearly
finished with a monstrous castle at Harrenhal,
too large and too costly a seat to rule only
the Riverlands.
King Argilac knew where the Ironborn would
soon turn.
You'd think a king who wanted to keep his
crown would be wary of a man with fire-breathing
monsters, but King ArgilacDurrandon wasn't
called "the Arrogant" for nothing.
Determined to arrest decline, he sent an envoy
to Dragonstone to enlist Aegon Targaryen and
his dragons against his enemies.
In exchange, Argilac offered lands he didn't
have, and a wife Aegon didn't need.
For as the Valyrians did, Aegon had wed his
elder sister Visenya.
Then as the Valyrians didn't, he took the
younger Rhaenys as well.
Two sisters, two wives.
Perhaps that's why he was so keen to get off
Dragonstone.
Aegon countered Argilac with courtesy.
He sent his own envoy requesting that Princess
Durrandon's hand be given instead to Aegon's
closest friend and rumored half-brother, Orys
Baratheon.
Argilac answered with a box and a note: "These
are the only hands your bastard shall have
of me."
Inside the box were the hands of Aegon's envoy.
How long had Aegon been waiting for such a
pretext?
As his army prepared to sail, ravens flew
to every great lord of the Seven Kingdoms.
All bore the same message: From this day forth,
there would be but one king in Westeros.
Those who bent the knee to Aegon of House
Targaryen would keep their lands and titles.
Those who took up arms against him would be
thrown down, humbled and destroyed.
Poor old Argilac.
He couldn't even match Aegon in arrogance.
Aegon landed at the mouth of the Blackwater
River and raised a primitive Aegonfort in
the disputed lands between Harren's and Argilac's
kingdom so that neither could decide whose
problem he was.
Adopting the customs of the Seven Kingdoms,
Aegon unfurled his own banner with a red three-headed
dragon breathing fire upon a black field.
Visenya crowned him with a ruby-studded circlet
of Valyrian steel while Rhaenys hailed him
as the first high king the continent had seen
since the Dawn Age.
As his lords and the gathered locals cheered
him, Aegon named his loyal friends to a small
council led by Orys Baratheon, whom he called
"my strong right hand."
The title stuck, and a bastard became the
first Hand of the King.
But for now, Aegon's kingdom contained only
a rocky island and a handful of fields.
The other kings had large armies, ships, castles,
and thousands of years of rule.
But Aegon had dragons.
He had chosen for the words of his house,
"Fire and Blood."
Before he was done, the rivers, fields, and
skies would turn red.
Euron Greyjoy: Harren of House Hoare inherited
a kingdom that stretched from the Iron Islands
to the Trident.
Too great a kingdom to rule from a castle
as shit as Pyke.
For forty years, his ironborn plundered the
Riverlands for stone, timber, and slaves to
build a seat worthy of him.
Legend has it that masons laid the final stone
in Harrenhal on the very day that Aegon landed
in Westeros.
Could've been a divine omen.
Could've been the masons wanted to go off
before the dragons got there.
They weren't the only ones.
At Aegon's approach, Harren'sriverlords revolted,
led by House Tully.
I doubt Harren noticed.
Harrenhal could repel an army of a million
men.
No ladder could summit its walls, and ram
could shatter them.
The castle was as impregnable as an old maid's...
Harren shut his gates around himself, his
sons and his ironborn, and waited for Aegon's
army to drain back into the muck.
When Aegon finally saw the monstrous castle,
he asked for parley.
Harren granted it.
Valyria had been the greatest empire the world
had ever seen.
Harren wanted to piss on its ashes.
Viserys Targaryen: (as Aegon) "Yield now,
and you may remain Lord of the Iron Islands.
Yield now, and your sons will live to rule
after you.
You see my army outside your walls.
You see my dragons."
Euron: (as Harren) "What is outside my walls
is of no concern.
Those walls are strong and thick."
Viserys: (as Aegon) "Dragons fly."
Euron: (as Harren) "But stone doesn't burn."
Viserys: (as Aegon) "When the sun sets, your
line shall end."
Euron: Harren spat and returned to his castle.
Once inside, he promised lands, riches, and
Tully's daughters to whoever could bring down
Aegon or his dragon.
As the sun sank below the horizon, all Harren's
men patrolled the battlements, hearing wings
in every gust of wind.
But the moon rose and sank, and no dragon
appeared.
Viserys: While the ironborn were ringing the
battlements, Aegon drove his dragon Balerion
higher and higher in the night sky, so that
even the great castle of Harrenhallooked like
an anthill below them.
Then they plunged straight into the castle,
well inside the guarded walls.
The five towers of Harrenhal reached towards
Aegon like a hand.
Balerion opened his mouth and bathed all the
fingers in flame.
Euron: Harren was right.
Stone doesn't burn, but men do, even when
they're ironborn.
The dragon blasted my ancestors into ash that
choked the survivors when they screamed.
Harren's soldiers leapt from the battlements
and died.
They huddled against the walls and died.
They fled across the yard and died.
Harren and his sons took shelter inside the
castle.
The stone didn't burn, but as Balerion blasted
it with fire, it glowed white-hot.
The world's greatest castle became the world's
greatest oven, baking the last of House Hoare
within it.
Viserys: Outside the castle walls, the towers
of Harrenhal glowed red against the night
and began to twist and melt like five huge
candles, with liquid stone trickling down
their sides like wax.
The next morning, Aegon forged a new Riverlands.
He named the rebel Edmyn Tully as his Lord
Paramount of the Trident and had the other
riverlords swear him fealty as their new liege.
For centuries, House Hoare had terrorized
the Riverlands.
Under House Tully, the Riverlands would, at
last, return to peace and prosperity.
After the castle cooled enough to allow men
inside, Aegon ventured into the ruin he had
made of Harrenhal.
He saw the ashen bodies, the scorched stone,
and the mangled and melted swords of his former
enemies.
To his men's confusion, he ordered these useless
swords collected and sent to his Aegonfort.
Varys: While Aegon marched on Harrenhal after
his coronation, Orys Baratheon had taken most
of his forces, and his queen Rhaenys with
her dragon, south to deal with the excuse
for the invasion: Argilac the Arrogant, King
of the Stormlands.
Argilac had his seat at Storm's End, a castle
considered the most impregnable in Westeros
after Harrenhal.
Argilac may have been arrogant, but he wasn't
stupid or a coward.
His lords advised him to shut his gates and
wait out the siege, but he'd heard what had
happened at Harrenhal and refused to die a
suckling pig cooked in his own castle.
He would meet victory or defeat the same way,
with sword in hand.
He called his banners and marched to meet
Orys Baratheon in the field.
Thanks to Rhaenys' dragon, Meraxes, Orys knew
Argilac was coming, how many men he had, and
how fast he marched.
So Orys simply seized the high ground and
dug in on the hills to wait for Argilac.
As the two armies approached, the wind rose
to meet them, and the rain poured from the
sky, a gale which would give the battle its
name: the Last Storm.
King Argilac's lords urged him to wait for
the weather to die down, but the Storm King
saw that the rain was blowing into the faces
of the Baratheon men on their hills and Argilac
outnumbered the Baratheon host two to one,
with four times as many knights and heavy
horse.
Argilac attacked.
Three times Argilac led his knights against
the Baratheon line, but the hills were steep,
and the rain had beat the earth mud.
The warhorses foundered and slipped, and the
chargers collapsed.
The battle seemed lost until Argilac ordered
the spearmen up the hill.
Blinded by the rain, the Baratheons didn't
see them until it was too late.
One hill fell, then another and another until
only one remained in the Baratheon center.
If Argilac could break through there, he could
split the invading army and flank both halves.
Argilac and his men charged, and the Baratheon
line broke, revealing Queen Rhaenys and Meraxes.
Argilac's vanguard burst into flame, and his
men panicked.
The victory charge fell into chaos, and Argilac
himself was thrown from his horse.
But he didn't yield.
When Orys Baratheon arrived, he found the
old king holding off half-a-dozen men, another
half-dozen dead at his feet.
Orys dismounted to meet the king on equal
footing and offered Argilac one final chance
to yield.
Argilac cursed him instead.
As the storm raged around them, the grizzled
old warrior and the bearded upstart fought
for life and kingdom.
In the end, Argilac got his wish.
He died, sword in hand.
As word of Argilac's death spread, his lords
and knights threw down their swords and fled.
Orys and his vanguard rode to Storm's End
to claim Argilac's castle for Aegon, only
to find the gates barred and the walls manned.
Argilac's daughter had assumed his crown,
and the new Storm Queen was as fond of yielding
as her father.
She declared that Orys would win only bones,
blood, and ashes here.
But her men were weaker than her, and that
night Orys found Argilac's daughter delivered,
gagged, chained, and naked to his camp.
Argilac had refused to give Orys her hand.
Now, Orys could have any part of her he wished.
But Orys unchained the girl, wrapped his cloak
around her, and poured her a glass of wine.
He told her he would take the arms, banner,
and words of House Durrandon to honor her
father's courage in the Last Storm.
Conveniently, Orys had none of his own to
discard first.
The crowned stag became the sigil of House
Baratheon, and Storm's End their seat.
Argilac's daughter would even remain in her
home, though, as a lady instead of a princess.
The Stormlands were now Aegon's, and as tribute,
Aegon demanded the swords of the men Orys
had defeated.
For what purpose, Orys didn't know.
Jaime Lannister: Aegon now ruled two of the
Seven Kingdoms, but he would no longer be
able to take the rest piecemeal.
For the first time in thousands of years,
the kings put aside their squabbles and joined
forces against a common enemy.
My ancestor, King Loren of House Lannister,
was head of the wealthiest family in the Seven
Kingdoms.
When King Loren joined his forces to Mern
of House Gardener, King of the Reach, they
had the mightiest army in history, a so-called
iron fist to break the would-be conqueror.
But while an iron fist can smash a man's face
in battle, you'd look silly hunting birds
or beasts with it, and Aegon had a creature
that was both.
The kings had never even seen a dragon, let
alone fought one.
They had fought each other for thousands of
years, and victory always went to the larger
army.
Surely a force five times that of Aegon's
could manage one dragon.
But Aegon arrived with three.
Still, the Lannisters and Gardeners hoped
for victory.
The battlefield they chose was a wide plain
with firm ground and clear skies.
Perfect for archers and mounted cavalry.
But neither of the kings spared a thought
for why the ground was firm.
There had been no rain for a fortnight, which
meant all the wheat and grass on it were bone-dry.
Perfect for dragons.
At first, the kings looked like they would
emerge victorious.
When the horn blew for battle, their armies
swept around Aegon's flanks, and their iron
fist of mounted knights smashed through his
center before the dragons could even enter
the fray.
But then Aegon and his sisters took flight
and unleashed their dragons, not on the soldiers,
but on the dry fields all around them.
The iron fist unclenched and became a hand
outstretched for mercy.
As Aegon promised, he had none.
More than four thousand men died in the fires,
another thousand escaping them.
Tens of thousands returned home as monsters,
burned and scarred beyond recognition.
House Gardener never returned at all.
The Field of Fire, as the singers call it,
claimed the last of the Gardener line, and
House Tyrell rose in their stead as Lords
of the Reach and Wardens of the South.
As for my illustrious ancestor, when King
Loren saw the battle was lost, he rode through
a wall of flame and smoke to safety.
Or at least to a heroic capture a day later,
where he lay his sword before Aegon and knelt.
Aegon, true to his word, spared him and confirmed
House Lannister as Lords of Casterly Rock
and Wardens of the West.
Why wouldn't he?
A Lannister always pays his debts, and now
we owed our lives to the crown.
That was worth centuries of subservience,
at least.
Besides, Aegon had a fetish for collecting
swords, not heads.
He added Loren's to the pile his men had retrieved
from the Field of Fire and sent them back
to the Aegonfort.
Sansa Stark: With most of the South in Aegon's
hands, the best chance to throw back the Conqueror
now lay with the North, if we cared enough
to try.
Unlike our southern rivals, the Stark Kings
of Winter didn't forge the North into one
kingdom for glory or gold (there is little
of either here), but to survive.
Alone in Westeros, the North remembered when
worse than dragons lay waste to armies.
Thousands of years ago, the sun set on the
realms of men, and the Long Night began.
A new race emerged from the ice and snow:
the White Walkers.
They demanded no crown, offered no terms,
spared no life, and the dead marched with
them.
With humanity facing extinction, a Stark sought
out the Children of the Forest, the most ancient
beings in Westeros, and convinced them to
ally with the men they'd once fought.
Together, the two races pushed the Walkers
back into the Land of Always Winter and sealed
it off from the Seven Kingdoms with the Wall,
three hundred miles of ice, stone, and earth
rising nearly seven hundred feet tall.
To guard it, they established the Night's
Watch, a brotherhood sworn to defend the living
from the dead, whose vows erase both titles
and crimes.
Viserys Targaryen: After the Long Night, the
North tried to forget it belonged to a continent.
Perhaps through pride, perhaps through sheer
ignorance.
You never can tell with the North.
But as news of Aegon's dragons spread, Torrhen
Stark, the King of Winter, knew he couldn't
forget Westeros any longer and summoned his
lords to Winterfell.
Many fools shrugged off the threat while the
rest placed wages on how long the South would
take to burn.
Torrhen silenced them with a command to assemble
their armies and descend from the North in
force.
Sansa: As the kings of the Rock and the Reach
burned on the Field of Fire, the greatest
Northern force since the Long Night crossed
the Neck into the Riverlands.
But when King Torrhen arrived at the Trident,
he saw on the opposing riverbank the combined
strength of all Aegon's conquered kingdoms.
A force larger than Torrhen's own by half,
and with three dragons.
Viserys: That night, King Torrhen called a
conference of all his lords and advisors.
Some wanted to fight and trust Northern valor
to carry the day (and burn on the Trident).
The wisest of them wanted to withdraw to Moat
Cailin, the fortress which had thrown back
every southern invasion (and burn there).
One suicidal lord even wanted to ambush Aegon's
camp in the dark and kill the dragons as they
slept or at the very least, their riders.
Hard to tell what would have been his fate.
Burning?
Beheading?
Dismemberment?Perhaps all three.
Sansa: My ancestor listened to their counsel,
and, in the morning, crossed the Trident under
a flag of parley.
Then King Torrhen of House Stark laid his
ancient crown at Aegon's feet and was named
Lord of Winterfell and Warden of the North.
Viserys: And the King Who Knelt.
Sansa: He had no choice, and thanks to him,
our soldiers returned to their homes whole
and unharmed.
The swords that Aegon took from them were
not twisted, burnt, or mangled.
Viserys: Yet.
Petyr Baelish: The Vale of Arryn was the last
of the great kingdoms left.
Old and proud, House Arryn did what they always
did in times of strife: they shut the Bloody
Gate, sealing off the Vale.
Then, the Queen Regent Sharra of House Arryn
retreated with her son, the boy-king Ronnel,
into the Eyrie, their family's impregnable
fortress.
From the top of their mountain, they could
look down on Westeros far below, its problems
hidden beneath the clouds.
But one day, Queen Sharra entered the outer
courtyard to find her young son sitting on
the knee of Visenya Targaryen and ogling her
dragon, Vhagar, beside her.
Just as he asked for another cake at dinner,
little King Ronnel asked his mother if he
could ride on the nice lady's dragon.
Visenya smiled at Sharra.
So, Sharra imagined, did Vhagar.
Remembering her manners, Sharra asked if she
could have Visenya brought some wine or food,
she must be tired after such a long flight.
But Visenya demurred.
Bored with his mother's pleasantries, Ronnel
demanded an answer.
Poor boy.
He didn't even understand the question.
Sharra hesitated for a moment, then asked
Visenya, as a mother, if it was safe for the
boy.
Visenya assured her it was.
What choice did Sharra have?
Whilst her son circled the castle, she collected
his little ringlet, her own regent's coronet,
and the ancient Falcon Crown of Mountain and
Vale, which the Arryns had worn for thousands
of years.
Ronnel had taken to the sky as a king, but
he landed as a lordling.
Perhaps he considered his ancient rights a
fair trade for a few minutes of flight, as
a little boy would.
More likely, he didn't even notice the three
crowns at Visenya's feet or recognize the
swords of his garrison beside them.
Viserys Targaryen: The heads of Westeros had
bowed to Aegon, but its heart still beat free.
Oldtown, the center of the Faith of the Seven.
There dwelt the High Septon, the father of
the faithful, who commanded the obedience
of all Westeros, save the savages of the North
and their Old Gods.
When Aegon had landed in Westeros, the High
Septon had locked himself in the Starry Sept
and fasted for seven days and seven nights,
one for each of his gods.
All he received for his trouble was the divine
wisdom that if Oldtown took up arms against
the dragon, the city would burn, faithful
and faithless alike.
After the submission of House Stark, Aegon
marches towards Oldtown, steeling himself
for another battle.
But he found the gates open, with the High
Septon welcoming him.
The pious fool even had the arrogance to grant
what Aegon had already won, and anointed the
last Valyrian as "Aegon of House Targaryen,
First of His Name, King of the Andals and
the First Men, Lord of the Seven Kingdoms
and Protector of the Realm."
As if titles meant anything to a man to whom
time itself now bowed.
The maesters would hence divide all history
into Before and After Conquest.
Most expected Aegon to stay and make Oldtown
his seat, but soon after his coronation, Aegon
returned to the mouth of the Blackwater River,
where he had first set foot on Westeros.
A small town had since sprouted around his
primitive fort.
To honor their new master, the locals dubbed
it "King's Landing," though it looked more
fit for a hedge knight, with wooden palisades,
muddy streets, and piles of mangled swords
carted in from every corner of the conquest.
But when Aegon made it his court, wood became
stone, black mud was buried beneath a Red
Keep, and the collected swords of Aegon's
foes were blasted by dragon fire and became
a seat fit for the Conqueror and the greatest
dynasty this world has ever known.
House Targaryen.My family.My throne.
Or so it should have been.
Varys: But while Aegon titled himself Lord
of the Seven Kingdoms, in reality, he held
only six.
The seventh, Dorne, had never knelt.
Visenya had flown into the Vale and returned
with its crown.
Mimicking her sister, Rhaenys had flown over
the enemy force holding the passes into Dorne
and landed in the castle of its ruling lady,
Princess Meria of House Martell.
Meria was eighty years old, fat, bald, and
blind.
Behind her back, many sniggered at her as
the "Yellow Toad of Dorne."
The beautiful Rhaenys probably thought as
much when they met.
She demanded Princess Meria kneel to her brother
Aegon, though she allowed that on account
of Meria's age and health, a simple vow of
submission would do.
But the princess told the queen that the Targaryens
weren't wanted in Dorne, and no Martell would
ever bow, bend or break no matter how badly
they burned.
Rhaenys could have mounted her dragon right
then, and roasted Meria in the castle as her
brother had done at Harrenhal.
But whatever she saw in Meria's eyes scared
her right back to King's Landing, with a dragon's
tail between its legs.
After Aegon's coronation, Rhaenys returned
to Dorne with Aegon and Visenya and their
dragons.
But no armies met them in the field, and no
lords defied them in their castles.
As the dragons approached, Dorne simply emptied.
House Martell had learned from Harrenhal and
the Field of Fire.
The dragons were unbeatable in battle, but
wars were more than battles.
Unopposed, Aegon claimed Dorne for his own.
But as soon as he returned to King's Landing,
his castellans were hurled off towers, and
his royal garrison vanished in the desert,
never to be seen again.
Except, perhaps, when the winds change and
the sands cough up old bones and armor.Rhaenys
returned on Meraxes, intent on avenging herself
against Meria Martell.
But Dorne was no longer empty.
The Dornish kept Meria's promise and fought
even while burning under dragon flame.
And they won.
One day a bolt pierced the eye of Meraxes
and knocked the dragon out of the sky.
House Martell remained unbroken, unlike the
unfortunate Rhaenys.
In their wrath, Aegon and Visenya set flame
to every castle and city but Sunspear, trying
to turn the people against House Martell.
But the Dornish stayed loyal, and when Aegon
returned to King's Landing, he found assassins
waiting for him in the streets of his own
capital.
If not for Visenya, the Conqueror would not
have enjoyed his conquest for very long.
From then on, the king and his family would
be guarded by the seven greatest knights in
the realm: the Kingsguard.
When Meria died in her sleep, a weak and tired
son sued for peace.
But old Meria had exhausted Aegon as well,
and he granted the request.
The Targaryens still wanted Dorne, and eventually,
they would have it, but not at the point of
a sword.
They would buy it the same way great lords
buy anything: with a daughter.